we're the only ngo here in del rio
who works with migrants the past two
weeks
have definitely been
extraordinary in
as far as numbers go in just three days
we assisted over a thousand families
we've been able to continue with our
mission of providing
food and lunches
and helping organize coordinate
the best
transportation option for families
it's it's not their intent
to stay in
del rio they want to
reunite with their loved ones and if we
weren't here
i think it would be
pretty tricky for them to figure out uh
how to
get from del rio to wherever their final
destination is the support from the
community has been phenomenal we have
hygiene kits
we have diapers and wipes and another
example would be
there have been quite a few newborns
that have been born at our local
hospital
and once they are processed through
border patrol they would come here so
now we're having to add swaddling
blankets and
some newborn
items uh for moms
so
that but that's always been in place
we're just seeing it in bigger numbers